hey guys welcome to this week's episode
of congratulations
yeah guys what is
frigging dude what is
freaking up gotta say frigging more like
a mormon
you know i have to actually because i
have a kid
and i just have a potty mouth
and i don't need to have a potty mouth
around my kid because
pretty soon he's going to be at the of
the age
where one time my my grandma
was changing my cousin nick's diaper and
he couldn't talk
and he wasn't like letting her change
the diaper and she says oh you're full
of [ __ ] and he says
for [ __ ] and matt and i laughed and
laughed
and laughed and matched my brother if
you're not a listener if you are
you know how matt is um yeah so
you know i'm i'm i'm doing actually a
bunch of episodes in a row here so i
don't know
what's which ones are going to come out
when which one's going to
come out before or after or whatever but
um news came out today
that uh dmx passed away and
it was a little bit like is he did he
pass away or not for like
four days and um i just kind of listened
to
his album a little bit and um
i um god that guy was just [ __ ]
talented you know
like some guys were just rough around
the edges but
had it and it just kind of f
like flowed through them um and he was
that way i felt when i was
not when i was what was i when it came
out 1997 i think the first uh album
maybe 99 i think it's 97 and i was a
huge tupac fan
obviously you know i still am but when
the [ __ ] when that dark man
x [ __ ] came out first of all when i
first heard that song
the first song i heard was when my dog
said
and i was just like this guy's really
barking he's really really barking
this guy is ellen barking and
uh he's like butters you know what i
mean
and that the cover was cool
and i was just like finally someone does
it
you know i was like maybe he's not as
good as tupac but he's doing it like
that
on that level and um i
just loved his stuff um
it was just the right amount of dark to
i mean because like dude you would like
i was a [ __ ]
17 year old kid in la canada and i would
be listening to that and i would be like
you know what
it is dark and hell [ __ ] is
hot dude like and he the thing about him
is
he knew it so i knew it you understand
you can get to a level of artistry where
you're telling someone the truth and
that's your truth
artistically and whether or not they
think that
they believe it while you're saying it
and that's when a song can
[ __ ] knock you out or you know a
painting you look and you're just like
wow or whatever it is
um and that's what he had man so i
wanted to start this
uh off with just
appreciation for him man because
man that [ __ ] was i mean he he was he
was [ __ ]
he was good dude and his music will live
on
and i don't know if the [ __ ] kids
like it but i'm gonna make calvin listen
to it when he gets so
older and i'm gonna be like see
son it is dark and hell
is hot um
god dude the lawnmower
sits right next to the tree that
that's it and that no there are so many
good dmx lines
i'm from 40 foot i'm from 44th street
and blah blah blah
the most gangster street of all time um
where you from where you from oh i live
in
union square what like 14th and yeah
14th and
10th where are you from i'm from 44th
street blah blah blah
i'm from 44th street and black black bav
uh i love hip-hop that doesn't even
really try but also tries you know
he's like like i said when [ __ ] uh
what's his name um
guru our recipes guru but when he when
he said
i love the cutie pies never the duty
pies and i'm just like dude
he doesn't love the duty pies that's
what makes him special
he's not just saying this [ __ ] he's not
bow wow you're yaying over it he means
it
um
anyway so that's what's up um
what does and you can't even like if
you're in a
a [ __ ] in public what do you want
from
what these want from the radio version
what a person wants from somebody
[Laughter]
just so vague what a person wants from
somebody
come on and let me know huh if you heard
that the first time
what what a person wants
from somebody love
no the exact opposite
um yeah so
love it what these brodies want fr why
did they
what's that what's that jaw rule that
was a jaw rule thing come on
jaboo um ja rule was like the game show
game show host version of of dmx
dmx was like uh uh yes and charles was
like come on now contestant number one
come on damn we're gonna guess what
you got to say a bunch of stuff and we
got to guess the now
you understand lisa you ready
yeah your partner is dan
say hi dan hi all
all right elise is gonna have to tell
you what something is
without actually seeing what it is
okay all right here we go
go um it's like a
murder it's murder
okay this was a really bad idea to have
jaw rule host this
[ __ ] pyramid game
okay ja rule god damn it man we it's
hard to edit it out because we're all on
the same audio channel
my bad my bad we couldn't use dmx he's
two street we got you because you're the
game show host version of dmx right my
bad
so can we please yeah here we go hey
carl say hi carl hi
your partner is jake
you gotta say a bunch of stuff without
saying the word go alright for first so
first of all
it's ah it's murder
all right um same joke twice that's what
i do
that's what i do i don't do it once
because i want to do it twice sometimes
i want to do it three times
sometimes you're lucky i don't do it
four times dude
how about [ __ ] kristen she has to
live with me i do the jokes sometimes
[ __ ] 20 times until people laugh and
then i kick back and relax
back to reality oops um
yeah dude that's how it is and it's dark
and hell
is hot dude what do you think hell's
room temp
no um
so yeah uh i uh i wrote some stuff down
actually man because there was stuff i
missed
um in the uh oh i cut my hair
a little bit more dude i gotta stop i'm
like a [ __ ] heroin addict with my
hair
i'm gonna i'm gonna show up one day i'm
gonna be like bruce willis they're gonna
be like why is
why is [ __ ] why is bruce willis
hosting congratulations
um yeah dude i i [ __ ] it's so short
it's getting shorter but the thing is i
saw a picture of me and the [ __ ] was
popping out like the back of my head was
popping out like i looked like jfk a
little bit taking a ride in a cadillac
and i'm just like
gotta cut that um
and um so yeah so i had to [ __ ]
do that and then i cut my hair and now
it looks [ __ ]
good dude and kristen videotaped me
cutting it and there
dude she was trying to make fun of me
with a friend and guess what didn't
matter
because i [ __ ] internalized it and
stood stronger that's what you gotta do
when somebody makes fun of you
you gotta breathe in and just
stand like an archangel inside your body
not actually stand like an archangel but
imagine yourself
standing you know how they'd say like
bruce lee is like you you
the one inch punch you're supposed to
punch
through the chest you're supposed to
punch through the chest
envision punching through through the
chest that's what i would do
when someone makes fun of me i stand
like an archangel and then you know
obviously when it gets way too hot and
thousands and thousands and thousands of
people are making fun of you you get
really depressed but anyway
dude um you know you go up and down life
and it's just [ __ ] like today i was
just i found myself talking to my friend
and we were having a real conversation
and all of a sudden
broke the [ __ ] down and the sweetest
thing about it was man
um he broke the [ __ ] down too with me
and that's what you know
that's when you know you got a [ __ ]
road dog you know
and it's like it may be dark and hell
may be hot but we're both here
together um so yeah so that's where i'm
at
definitely you know whatever but it's
good and now i feel good because i drank
a little bit of coffee and i started
thinking about dmx and he made me feel
good about that [ __ ]
and uh so [ __ ] life rips again but
life always rips
just remember life always rips bottom
line
life always rips because it is what you
make it no matter what
just live inside your head baby just
live inside your head
uh that's what i do i love thinking
about [ __ ] during the day just thinking
just drifting off and just thinking
you ever do that you ever doing like
either
either working so hard day after day or
just
actually not day after day just chilling
sometimes you're just into the mundane
process of the day and then you just
drift off man you just drip drip the
[ __ ] off and you start thinking about
[ __ ] you just start thinking about
anything man
sometimes i think about [ __ ] like
today i thought about oh man christmas
was fun with my family
you know i just had the that week or two
where we were just chilling and nothing
was going on in the world and we were
just hanging having a good time and
it was calvin's first christmas and yeah
he cried when i was santa but
it was just nice and then i remember
also i put my contact in my eyes and for
some reason
my eye my eye it was [ __ ] it was
hellishly burning
my eye dude how come so this has
happened two or three times in my life
i put my contact in and all of a sudden
it's armageddon it's armageddon in my
eyeball and dude
i get pissed because why is it
armageddon in my eyeball
that's what i want to know okay now it
was armageddon in my eyeball
on christmas this past christmas i put
my contact in my eye and all of a sudden
if you ever have like hot heat in your
eye if you have hot hot heat in your eye
the eye shuts dude it's like one of
those star wars doors that you're never
gonna get through it just goes
and your eye is shut 15 minutes bare
minimum
dude bare minimum 15 minutes and i
and i walked out in christmas with my
eye and i was like
ma now i'm 40
and i'm screaming at my mom because my
eye hurts now why am i doing that is
because i'm a [ __ ] no it's cause i'm at
her house
if i was at my house i would just
internalize it
breathe like an archangel and chill and
be pissed at myself
because my situation got me there but
i'm staying at my parents house over
christmas eve on christmas morning
i wash my hands with my mom's soap and i
put this thing in my eye
and it shuts like a star wars door now
you look at the difference you look at
what you were doing
and you look at what you are doing what
have i been doing putting my contact in
for the last however many years
well i've been at my house or i've been
in a hotel room or i've been
in well those are the only two places
but this time i was at my mom's house so
my eyes shut like a star wars door
and i walk out and i say ma i'm blind
what's the deal with the soap and she
said huh i said it hurts so [ __ ] bad
you don't understand and she was like oh
it's fine and i
and that was the thing that [ __ ] took
the knife
from inside my belly to up into my chest
dude
my mom looked at me and goes like this
the knife was already in because my
eyeball was hurting and she goes like
this
ah it's okay so now i have a huge gash
on my stomach metaphorically
but my eyes shut realistically
and i say well what the [ __ ] is going on
is it so what's in the soap what's in
the soap acid dude did you drop the
joker in there
what's going on with that man
and she's like no it's fine just watch
it again and then put the [ __ ] it's
okay sorry you'll get over it
and i'm mad because when i'm upset i
want people to be upset with me dude
when i'm upset
i want everybody in the room to be upset
with me so we can all get through it
okay
that's just how your boy lives that's
your boy's
truth okay
so i was like all right [ __ ] it man it's
one eye i still got the other so i
travel back to the bathroom that has way
too many tchotchkes in it because
my mom ah has so many tchotchkes dude
it's unbelievable it's like
it's like the room where they found the
[ __ ] holy grail in indiana jones but
we were like what the [ __ ]
what is all this [ __ ]
and she treats each object like it's the
actual holy grail and she's like this is
the one
this needs to go here this kleenex box
goes on top of this ceramic cat
and i'm sitting there like all right
whatever just get out let me do my other
[ __ ] contact please
so i take my other contact i wash my
hands thoroughly and i take my other
contact put it in my
eye guess what dude i guess we're doing
the star wars trilogy because this one
shuts like a [ __ ] star wars door too
and now i'm screaming i'm screaming dude
and here's who you're at my who's at my
house me my mom
my dad my brother my brother's
girlfriend and also kristen
and i'm saying hey ma what the [ __ ] i
can't see [ __ ] it's so blurry
i walk outside across the living room
across the kitchen
into the other bathroom to [ __ ] wash
my eyes out okay
nobody's saying [ __ ] i get i'm 40.
but come on dude have some compassion
nobody's saying [ __ ]
i can't see [ __ ] it's a miracle i even
got to the other bathroom
i'm like [ __ ] red charles in this
[ __ ] i knew where i was going i'm
spider-man
because i heard my mom being like and
i'm like
it's bouncing off me and i'm like if
she's over there then that ricocheted
off the island the kitchen island and
then [ __ ] bounced off the ceramic cat
and then the tissues sound like it
muffled it so the bathroom must be over
here
i'm not spiderman daredevil who gives a
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude
they're all red daredevil spiderman
superman
get different colors dude make a new
color marvel dc whatever the [ __ ] it is
image comics and um so anyway dude
i'm in the other bathroom now i'm in two
bathrooms that's how much my eyes hurt
and i'm crying my eyes out not because
i'm sad but because i mean i am sad
internally but because my eyes are
[ __ ] burning i'm sad because my
situation but the eyes
are burning that's why i'm crying i'm
not even crying because i'm sad like i
did today
i'm crying because i'm burning i'm not
crying
like i am sometimes when i get in the
car and i drive away and i think about
my situation i'm crying because my eyes
are burning because whatever the [ __ ] is
in my mom's
floral ass soap that you got it [ __ ]
apple cart
it's a store in la canada
[Music]
does they have much more than just
apples
and it's way bigger than a cart [ __ ]
call it things store
[Laughter]
dude oh yeah i want to walk in there and
be like oh yeah
is this really really hey dude can i get
a [ __ ] bag of apples oh you don't
have it um
i noticed that ceramic cap my mom has it
i'm [ __ ] out
and just moonwalk out um
anyway i [ __ ] hear my dad and he's
just like
chris and i'm just like no and i'm in
the other bathroom sitting on the toilet
it's i'm i have my pants on
and also the the seat's down i'm using
it like a chair and i'm like
i can't see dude do you understand it's
burning and my eyes are watering
and they're like it'll be okay and i'm
like okay but like
just [ __ ] say like ah [ __ ] man that
sucks
that's all i need and then and then i
need like 30 minutes later to be like
that [ __ ] sucked about my eyes huh
and then i need people to be like yeah
dude [ __ ] that sucks man does it
still like feel okay
it still hurt and i'd be like yeah it's
like a little residual but i'm okay
and then we can talk about whatever the
[ __ ] you want dude it's like my parents
won't give it to me dude
they won't [ __ ] give it to me i get
[ __ ] sad
yeah man i think there was a text chat
in here that you that you sent me about
it right
let's see what the [ __ ] text thing
was because i remember
i thought about this a bunch and um
it was like months later i think uh
let me look it up in my texts here uh
and uh i brought it up in the in the in
the family chat
it should be a here we go a screenshot
oh here we go yeah
and it was when was it um
i don't know what it was doesn't say but
i said just out of the blue this was
maybe not even a month ago
and i write you guys didn't react enough
when i burned my eyes on christmas
and my dad said by the way that no haha
bubbles no love bubbles no upper
not even they didn't even disrespect me
they anti-respected me
i got the anti-respect
none of that just give me a thumbs down
like i always say when you're in a
[ __ ] room and you're trying to do
stand-up
don't not laugh at least boo so i could
feel like somebody
laugh sure but don't not laugh don't be
the guy at the comedy show that's just
chilling you might as well have
sunglasses on and you're like
brought my date what
is it a ted talk at least boo at least
go boom
i want to know how you really feel man
so um
yeah i said you guys didn't react enough
when i burned my eyes on christmas and
then my dad writes
that's right we didn't and to add
insult to injury to take that knife
that's been
sitting there for months in my chest and
look me in the eyes
and push it up to my neck
someone gives him a haha
dude someone gives him a haha baba
so not only do i get no haha bubble when
i bring up the [ __ ] hilarity
my dad says that's right we didn't and
he gets a ha ha bubble
now i can't tell who did it because it's
a screenshot so you can't click on it
but i bet that that person is sitting
right here in this room right now
and then someone says oh no then my mom
says
and we never will okay so let's just
[ __ ] trace it back
you guys didn't i say you guys didn't
react out of the blue nobody was texting
each other all day i said you guys
didn't react enough when i burned my
eyes on christmas
my dad hits me back with that's right we
didn't someone
ha has him i didn't get one and then
after that my mom agrees with my dad and
says and we never will
and then my mom gets a ha ha okay now
this is why i'm really pissed
it's because my dad already did the joke
if you want to give him a ha ha and not
me the ha ha fine but don't give the
person who does the same joke after my
dad
another [ __ ] haha sure enough there's
a ha ha
and i have a feeling that the person who
did it is sitting right here in this
[ __ ] room right now
and then i write doubling down stand on
my ground dude
imagine myself as a [ __ ] archangel
sitting in my [ __ ]
absolute positivity
and i write back it really burned a lot
i get nothing dude
and then my mom writes
what a doofus
with an exclamation point have you heard
someone
call someone else at doofus in the past
25 years
because i didn't i only heard doofus
when the word doofus came out
and for a month or two it was gone after
that
my mom held on to that
like a seven-year-old me and some
halloween candy dude
i used to hold [ __ ] almond joys to
next halloween
and i'd be like mark can i still eat
this and she'll be like
hey son that's stale you doofus
then my dad follows up with my mom who
already slammed me
and he writes good thing you're texting
about it now though
sarcasm now if you read that in a script
it would say dripping with sarcasm above
it
no hahas then i write
because i know my son calvin agrees with
me
and my mom says prove it
and then my dad says a baby always
recognizes
another baby and he got a haha
and then i pretty much it was done but
then i said did you guys believe that it
hurt so much and then i don't see what's
beyond that because it was a text but it
was a screenshot
what a [ __ ] [ __ ] i am for real
whatever dude my parents made me
um and i met calvin and that dude pretty
much i'm sure
understands why my eyes were hurt so bad
i'm gonna tell him when he gets older
i'm gonna tell him you know one day
my eyes were hurt so bad and then this
happened and then
so that's what me and my family were
doing
i actually look i know who did the ha
has because kristen sent me the [ __ ]
screenshot and the haha are blue which
means that those are the ones that she
did for [ __ ] sake dude
i'm a detective i [ __ ] figured it out
and when you figure it out
that's the [ __ ] best feeling in the
world oh your hahas are blue
well i know who did it
[Music]
um so anyway
uh postmates won't stop ringing my
doorbell when i
order it all that happens is i [ __ ]
put up a sign that
says don't ring the doorbell please baby
you're sleeping
and they [ __ ] show up and uh there's
no way they don't see the sun
and they [ __ ] ring a door about i
know why oh wait no so here's what
actually happened
i [ __ ] put in the postmates thing
please don't ring the doorbell
a baby is sleeping they don't read the
notes on postmates apparently
and i can say that now because they're
not sponsors
of this show uber eats drivers
read the notes i write in ubereats
hey guys please
don't run the doorbell have a toddler
and every time i don't even know who
delivers the food it's like a goddamn
ninja works for ubereats sometimes i'm
just like
i hear i'm like oh the food's here
oh what the [ __ ] the food's here dude i
think i just saw a flash of a sword
getting in a [ __ ] prius
um i saw a [ __ ] uber driver an uber
eats guy with a
dope car today it was weird as [ __ ] this
pandemic is getting to everybody
um anyway
anyway uh so i get so sick of this
and when when your boy gets pissed he
works he works on it and he's been
working on it and he's been in therapy
for it over the last bunch of months and
he's trying to not get pissed because he
learned that anger
is a huge reason for why he is the way
that he is and he wants to just be
chilling
he wants to be sweet and kristen says be
nice and i say you know what you're
right
but when i say you know what you're
right i feel heat bubbling in my chest
so
i gotta get rid of that so talk to my
therapist about it and i try to be good
about it but this postmates thing it
happens every time
postmates shows up ding dong 11a i love
i tell
dude ding dong 11 pm
good thing my baby sleeps like a rock um
so yeah so i say you know what i'm
leaving a [ __ ] note
i'll show it on the podcast but i wrote
a note on half of a
paper towel with a sharpie and the note
was crinkled up
and i wrote leave food with an
arrow under it and then next to that i
wrote
no ring like a
[ __ ] i i mean it's not a paper towel
with a shart with a half
with a sharpie that's running out of ink
and it's spelled like a [ __ ] japanese
guy trying to learn english
leave a food no ring live
food so
i [ __ ] put it there
and kristen opens the door for something
else
during the day and she comes back and
when she comes back
she looks at me like it's raining
tomato soup cans outside and i say
what's going on and she goes are you
[ __ ]
kidding me and i'm like
this is about the cheating and she's
like no this is about the [ __ ]
this and she shows me the thing and it
looks like a [ __ ] ransom note
and she says this can't be on our front
door
and i say why not it's [ __ ] to the
point it's succinct and she says because
it looks like
a [ __ ] ransom note and i say well
what the [ __ ] who cares
and she says i care which is something
that i just won't ever understand who
cares it's just a sign
dude she ordered one on amazon that says
like
she was like so she was like not mad but
she was like you can't talk you can't
have this
you have to talk nice to people i'm like
even it's a sign just like even on a
sign
you can't just say leave food no ring
they're gonna be like oh the biggest
jackass of all time lives at the [ __ ]
it looks like it's on toilet paper to be
honest
it's just no respect and i'm like
they're not showing me [ __ ] respect
dude i come from a family do you
understand i come from a family my dad's
great uncle
used to go to this drug store and get
his medication and every time the guy
went
into the back room to get the medication
my uncle stole
something a little piece of thing
whatever it was
99 cents it was probably four cents back
then because it was [ __ ]
the year 1290 or however old it was when
my dad had a [ __ ] great grandpa
or a great uncle and one day
my grandpa went in his brother that
guy's brother
and he said listen
the drugstore guy said listen
um my dad told me the story when i was a
kid he said listen to this
to to my to my grandpa my dad's dad
um your brother you know he's i know
he's getting
older and um it doesn't really
it doesn't really bother me and i i
don't want to bring it up to him because
he's never really stealing anything big
but i know every time i go back to get
his pills he
he he takes something from the store and
i don't want to make a big deal out of
it but
could you maybe just talk to him and and
get him to stop doing it
this was back in the [ __ ] 40s or
whatever this is when people used to
just be like
hey let's work it out on our own you
know hey
look i know you're stealing from me but
you talk to him and you talk to the
other guy it's a real italian thing how
about you just talk to him and he'd talk
you have a talk you have a sit down you
used to sit down
you get jimmy to talk to him and then
paul you'll come in and you talk you
have a good time carmine's there
he'll give you his blessing and nobody
be stealing from anybody i could give
him his pills you understand i'm gonna
have to [ __ ] draw him out
so he my grandpa
grandpa bam used to call him because he
used to be skinny uh like a bamboo
stick which he wasn't by the time i was
alive but um
goes and he talks to his brother my
dad's great uncle and he says
now remember my dad told me this when i
was a kid
and he says hey um
i got to talk to you and my dad my
grandpa's brother i forget his name but
he says uh yeah
and he said bam says you know i i was at
the drugstore and the guy
the guy knows you're stealing from him
and uh he just doesn't he doesn't want
you to do it anymore
and uh that's all so if you could just
do it you know for me
and my dad's great uncle or my dad's
great uncle says
yeah yeah i know he knows
and my grandpa says huh
and he says i know he knows and he says
well if you know he knows why do you do
it and he said that's why i do it
his prices are ridiculous
he's robbing me so whenever he goes back
to get my pills that i have to pay high
price for
i take a little something so it's even
was the inception of uh
that was the uh inception dude
that was the [ __ ] four of them just
sitting in a van going backwards into
the [ __ ]
that lake bed in the movie
with [ __ ] leonardo dicaprio my
grandpa was leonardo dicaprio and my
[ __ ] great uncle was
tom hardy and then my dad was the asian
guy and then whoever else was the [ __ ]
in it we always forget
and they were just ah it was the
inception dude
and he's like my dad told me that when i
was [ __ ] like 10.
so my point is
postmates she's gonna ring the doorbell
he's gonna get he's not gonna listen to
the note on the app
he's gonna get a half-assed note on some
[ __ ] [ __ ] paper
with a half used sharpie written like a
[ __ ] japanese
that's what you're gonna get
i'm not [ __ ] what am i gonna do have
a streamer and a parade and a [ __ ] no
you [ __ ] with me you get a dirty sign
so i tell this to chris kristen and she
says
oh you're a crazy person
but i'm not dude tit for tat
anyway we now have a really nice flowery
frilly [ __ ] sign that we got from
amazon prime
and it looks stupid in front of the
doorway and it says please
on it and then don't ring the doorbell
we have a sleeping baby
so i'm a [ __ ]
and that's the [ __ ] story dude
[Music]
she's taking liberties it's my song now
dude
all good
that's got a [ __ ] ha my dad has a
toaster and
it's got too many buttons so i'm pissed
i see it and naturally i'm pissed
wow i see a toaster if it has more
than just four buttons i'm pissed so if
i enter your house
and i see your toaster and it's got five
or six buttons prepare for me to be like
hey let's have a sit down where's paulie
so he's got a [ __ ] button on his
goddamn toaster
that says a little more
oh all right
it has toasting and then it has the sham
button the [ __ ] extra money button
that they rip you from this toaster also
has
a button for just is this right
how can this be so you can toast it but
and then what is this here it says bagel
you can just do bag
so you can do bagels and it will toast
simply one side
of the bagel they got put in the right
way you got a toaster here
you have a thing at toast and you have a
bagel
you put the bagel in there you get one
until you get it maybe put on cream
cheese you put locks put whatever you
want put it on
and you put it on you taste it and that
is the best bag you ever had and we have
40 left and they are flying
off the shelves so my dad has the
toaster
and it costs way too much money and he
doesn't care because he's 72
and what the [ __ ] he gonna spend his
money on answer a toaster
and there's a button that says a little
more
i don't like this [ __ ] button this
button is making fun of me dude
i see that button and i feel like you
know what this is [ __ ] this button
because i could just hit the toast
button and then hit the toast button
again
and make it a little more as much as i
want to
but my dad's got the other and he wants
you to use the [ __ ]
a little more buttons so badly because
that's what the extra [ __ ] 50
was i hit a little more
dude that it's toasted the way i want
i'm just saying if it's a little
underdone
hit a little more it'll just do it a
little more or
i can just hit toast and then hit toast
again
and [ __ ] do it the way i want to he's
like yeah but it's got button for that
now
okay so i'm just saying
the way my dad is and the way he talks i
just
i know i do it it's like this the the
student surpassed the teacher
like [ __ ] three decades ago it was
he's stealing from me so i'm stealing
from him i don't care if he knows it or
not and now
it's well if postmates is gonna ring the
doorbell and he's not looking at the app
with the note on it then i'm gonna
[ __ ] disrespect him by writing a
[ __ ] shitty note
on a half of a half of a [ __ ] paper
towel
calvin's gonna be like i mean what the
[ __ ] is three generations from that
yeah he looked at me weird so what
happened was i walked over and i [ __ ] on
his escalade
what yeah sucks huh
but we are delis
calvin's son's gonna be like
like when they open the fridge in
ghostbusters and zod is in there
just gonna calvin's son's gonna be named
zod i'm gonna tell cal to name his son
zod kali and zod
calvin and zod making the world a worse
place sproul
cali and zod making the
making the world so confused why would
you [ __ ]
an escalade callion zod on after a show
with will sasso probably
um on abc
on abc directly after his show with
probably kyra sedgwick
um anyway
so what the [ __ ] was i talking about my
dad oh yeah so i dude i have a video of
it and i'll probably i'm gonna play it
maybe i'll post it on instagram or maybe
i'll [ __ ] just
put it on this podcast i don't know oh i
have it in my diet and i have it in my
text and i
have it in my text chat this is just
great
all right great so here's how the
[ __ ] oh my god dude
my dad's already bitching on my brother
in the beginning of this video
he's already bitching i don't even know
what he's doing now
because it was a while ago i don't even
remember and i can't tell what he's
doing now
but it's like the [ __ ] it's like the
beginning of the [ __ ] dmx intro and
it's dark as hell is hot after he's like
talking for a little bit and then the
music kicks in and he's just like man
he sounds like the [ __ ] guy in the
beginning
of the [ __ ] what's that song number
10 on its darkest hell is hot
what is it get down how's it going down
i believe i'ma call it man
that's what it sounded like i believe
this man go call it man i'll believe
this
hello who dick you suck in remember that
bro my [ __ ] my ears as a child just
what they can't put this on they can put
this on a disc
man i believe this don't call this me so
man
hello who dick you sucking what
just already mad that's what i love
about black people
if you come mad at a black person
that person matches how mad you are
immediately
a white person doesn't do that this is a
bit [ __ ] like
80s comedy but it's true dude a white
person if you're like hey buddy hey can
i have a can i [ __ ] have a
conversation with you
a white guy is going to be or a white
woman is a white male female they're
just going to be like
yeah what's the problem what's going on
here black people
dude if you're like hey man can i talk
to you for a second
that person is like yo what's up what's
up what you gonna do
and you're like oh [ __ ] man so if you're
a white guy and you don't know that
about black people
don't come at black people like that
you'll have to back the [ __ ] up just
like i
i so that's what my dad's doing he's
doing the beginning of how's it going
down right here you can hear it dude
oh my god dude you hear him
no it's not stupid so okay so he's
telling my brother that i did something
stupid
so i'm now in this position
who did you suck in this is me now okay
i took the bread and i [ __ ] and here
i am dude
johnny breaks it down because somebody
has to break it down
and my family breaks it down dude but
when i'm with my family
i break it down
no no it's not stupid already man took
the bread okay here's me i [ __ ]
cut it and i put it in the toaster i
decided after i put it in the toaster
it was too big and i thought it was
gonna get stuck the bread was too big
my dad has a toaster and he buys bread
that's too big to go in the toaster
okay so what johnny figures it out does
is
[Laughter]
i had to transform from johnny breaks it
down
real quick to johnny figures it out
[Laughter]
and then i had to go from johnny figures
it out
back to johnny breaks it down it was
like the quickest episode of
transformers you've ever seen
all right so now the bread's smaller
[Laughter]
so now the bread's smaller all right so
he came over and he said that's my dad
my dad comes over and he says
do you want to make it only toasting on
the inside or what he wants me to use
the goddamn bagel button
on a sandwich bread okay i don't need to
use the bagel button
because it's not a bagel you know how i
know it's not a bagel because it's too
long
for the [ __ ] toaster and a bagel is a
circle
okay let's keep it moving and i said
yeah sure and he said then hit bagel
okay so i just was not even i said okay
sure and he says then hit bagel and
he's so happy about it right so
he said it's also too big and i said
yeah it's too big so i took it out
told me the bread was too big i already
knew it was too big because i already
because i took it out and i cut it dude
all right
so he's telling me some [ __ ] i already
know by the way i'm just trying to make
a [ __ ] sandwich
and he's lurking in the background like
a goddamn
you know what i mean and everyone's
coming at me because the bread was
already inside yeah and i said hit
bagel if you just want to toast these
okay but you're saying something
out of order that's the thing dude i
wasn't even talking about that my dad
likes to talk about something else
that we're not talking about and that's
what makes the conversation so
convoluted
and that's why i had to develop into
being so
good that's why i'm [ __ ] johnny's
johnny figures it out at heart and this
isn't pulpit you're doing it like this
is pulp fiction and it's not it's a
straight movie
because you just it's not linear you're
saying something
out of order and this isn't pulpit
you're doing it like this is pulp
fiction and it's not it's a straight
movie
it's a narrative that starts from the
beginning and it ends at the end
okay my brother the [ __ ] peanut
gallery in the background
and i cut off the little piece of it and
to make it fit
i put it back in and i hit bagel
and dad says you you are you trying to
toast it
oh my god dude i cut the bread
i put it in the toaster i hit bagel and
my dad comes by you know how [ __ ]
annoying this is
a 72 year old man walks by
while i'm doing my business and says you
trying to toast it
dude what the [ __ ]
who are you [ __ ] what are you a
baseball color com well
you try to toast it here he's actually
trying to toast as goodly cut off a
little piece because the truth is the
bread was too long and his toaster was
and it has too many buttons
it's toasted nicely in a bagel fashion
yeah and he says well then i hit toast
and then he [ __ ] makes it like it's
my fault because he said hit bagel
no and then my brother says he said you
gotta hit start he didn't say i had to
hit start
he hit start and then he said hit bagel
so now i'm going backtracking it's like
i'm just trying to [ __ ] toast the
[ __ ]
i hit toast and then he says hit bagel
i literally heard him say you gotta hit
start and then you look down and said
you're going to tell me that he said i
already hit it
that was his fault yeah it's all his
fault yeah
no no it's not my fault what's my what
was my fault all of it except the very
end when he said
was wearing after when he said he got
hit and he had already
started your friend's done no
look then my dad comes in again
dude how annoying is this dude my dad
comes in again
and says your bread's done but in the
middle
of him saying the thing before that and
him
saying the bread's done i [ __ ] you not
he goes into the garage
for what looks to be no reason
dude that is so [ __ ]
disrespectful that we are in a
conversation
and he walks into the garage and comes
back and then tells me something that i
already
know
dude look at him that's the garage door
opening
oh he's throwing away a [ __ ] empty
water bottle that's where they put the
recycling
god that's [ __ ] disrespectful
your friend's done no i hit it so it's
it's done it's done because i only
wanted it lightly
[ __ ] toasted okay well then you could
push that
lever down look see that's the thing is
why i said i i hit the button so it
would come up
it's done because i made it done and
that's when he said you could hit that
button he was pointing to the button
that says
a little more dude he wants me to use
all the [ __ ] buttons
this sounds going to come out look
tasting like a [ __ ] trash it's going
to be
like a [ __ ] uh a log at [ __ ] um uh
uh what is that thing that i used to do
called what was that thing i used to do
called
my mind's going i need ginkgo biloba oh
yeah dude yes
i don't remember [ __ ] cub scouts not cub
scouts but [ __ ]
[ __ ] something guide indian god yes
probably actually that's racist now
shouldn't admit that definitely could
get canceled
ah indian guides yes that's what it was
i don't there's too many levers so many
buttons do you want a plate
yeah this is annoying now he's still
here hovering like a goddamn parakeet
trying to land on a statue
or a pigeon buttons do you want a place
yeah yeah i would like to play man do
you want to help me get a player
he said do you want a plate yeah you
know where the [ __ ] plates are
dick dude so this is how you get to the
postmates [ __ ]
why can't i get a plate on my [ __ ]
self dude why don't why do you have to
[ __ ] say do you want to yes dude i
love when i see videos of me and i agree
with me
yes i'm [ __ ] consistent i'll [ __ ]
decide
see what i'm seeing do you see what i'm
doing and then do you see how maybe i
could mess up even though i didn't mess
up
nice so it's more his fault than you
actually realized good
here you go chance through chen's
the the dog i threw him the extra piece
that didn't fit in the [ __ ] toaster
the end
so oh look oh now i [ __ ] dude [ __ ]
kristen takes a video from her phone of
me talking about this on the podcast
sends it to the [ __ ] family group
chat
and and and [ __ ] my dad literally
writes and i was right about the toast
you know what i'm texting him back right
now
no no
no and you know what he doesn't even
know what it was about at this point
i wrote him back no not looking at my
phone to the end of the podcast i love
my son so much i want to hold him
and just [ __ ] have him here and have
him in my neck like this i love him
so much i can't believe it and i just
want him to be like tata
all the time and sometimes he says it
and i perk up
and then he's onto something else and
it's fine but i get that little moment
where he says dadda
and i feel like a kite
flying above a beach somewhere dude
because it's the most loveliest feeling
ever ever ever in the world and i hold
him
and he squirms out every single time
because he never stops moving
this kid is like a shark he just
constantly is moving forward
and i love him and he takes steps and he
does the thing now where he takes steps
and stops himself and can balance and
then switches directions
and chain he's like one of those [ __ ]
one of the first remote control cars
where you're like back it up back it up
okay go ahead and make a
photo watch over the tree that's what
he's like a kid that can barely walk is
like a remote control car you got the
same energy
and uh i love him so much dude i love
him so much
and we get oh dude he [ __ ] loves
straws and i'm drinking and he's just
looking at my iced americana going
and i'm like [ __ ] and she says just
give it to him he's gonna hate it
and then he'll learn and then he won't
[ __ ] drink it anymore and i'm like
all right yeah you're right [ __ ] it
i give it to him he goes like this is
what he does he drinks the ice americano
he's 14 months
he drinks this iced americano and he
goes like this
it goes for more dude
this kid's my son
this kid came out like roast my coffee
where is my coffee is that in this
baggage no that's the placenta
are there coffee beans on this placenta
can we grind them and make them into
coffee
mama
what's your favorite color buddy brown
and tan that's the color of coffee
places
that's the color of caffeine empty life
i like a little bit of purple too that's
the color of the sun and coffee
entity that's my son dude
he went for seconds it's like a fat guy
at a buffet
just you gonna have that
so now he likes coffee dude still went
right to sleep caffeine
dumb bother him love my son
so much dude can't believe
i can't believe it's a real thing i
can't believe
i'm lucky enough
to be a father dude i can't believe it
man
and [ __ ] tearing up jesus [ __ ]
christ man i can't believe i'm lucky i i
i feel like how did this [ __ ] happen
how
am i so fortunate to have
such a good [ __ ] kid dude what a [ __ ]
jesus man this kid is my heart
dude i was watching um
what's the uh show
westworld
[Laughter]
this isn't a transition this is real
it's part of the thing
and in this show westworld which is
i'm not saying the show is not good but
it's definitely good for a few episodes
and uh the
guy in it the [ __ ] guy who's in
everything jeffrey wright
is is uh we find out in like episode
four he's a robot and he's in the actual
place it's not a spoiler because
honestly who gives a [ __ ]
you'll find out that he had a son that
died
and he is
forced with the option
to make the choice of do i erase him
from my brain
or do i keep the memories even though
they're so painful
and he says yeah but that's all i have
and i think before i was a dad oh jesus
christ
i would have thought oh man i'd erase
those memories man
they'd be too painful but man
my point is is that every day
even if it's just a day like it's just
it's the most amazing thing being a dad
that's what it's like when you when you
have a kid you're
uh somebody told me this but it's so
true
it unlocks doors uh
to the world and the universe that you
had no [ __ ] idea about
that's what it's like um
so all right that's it
[ __ ] that's it
i'm going to wear depends tonight maybe
see if it works for a [ __ ] fourth run
uh thanks for listening love you guys
uh thanks for your support for my
patreon
thank you for that my uh the merch is
still going strong
you guys are great representing with the
[ __ ] life rip [ __ ]
and then no [ __ ] diddly dunce um
uh and uh it's a [ __ ] lifestyle man
life rips if you wanted to and uh
there you go there's shorts there's a
bathing suit bro dip in the pool
show em life reps that's it for the show
catch the extended version uncut on my
patreon
patreon.com crystalia
[Music]
congratulations
you